[music]
>> All right, it is great to see you all. I
think most of you are here for the air
conditioning, but nonetheless
>> [laughter]
>> this will be good for you regardless.
So, welcome. That was a great dev
keynote earlier if you all got to watch
being able to see how much all of us
could create software from prompts, from
our voice, from context. How amazing is
that with anti-gravity 2.0, with AI
studio? This is amazing time to build.
So, we're going to have some fun today
doing a lot with this. Now, first we
just built this game in uh AI studio. If
you saw the dev keynote earlier, you saw
that they were building games, doing all
kinds of stuff. Let's have some fun. So,
when you build a game like this, you
might click publish. You might deploy it
to something like Cloud Run in Firebase.
And hey, no credit card required as you
start shipping your first two
applications, which is amazing. We all
love day one. Day one is amazing. You
ship it, you feel good. But then there's
day two. There's real traffic. There's
things that go wrong. There's edge cases
you haven't considered. So,
what I want to do though is, you know, I
want to introduce first my friends
Christina and then uh Denise are here to
help me out. They've built some amazing
things. Yes. [cheering]
They're both
both amazing. What I want you to do is
take out your phone, scan this QR code,
and let's play this game. Seriously. I
want to see if it can survive IO
traffic. I have my doubts.
Uh
Christina's job depends on this. There's
no stakes here. It'll be fine.
So, what I want to see, let's let's try
to play the game for a minute and see if
you all can break it with load or it'll
be completely fine and your job will be
safe. Either way,
it's not a big deal.
So, we're going to go here. We'll look
at the leaderboard, I think. We'll see
Oh, yeah. Let's I'm going to go.
You're unbelievable at the game, Denise.
So, let's see. Let's see if I could beat
this. It's looking good so far.
>> You only need to survive 10 seconds.
>> How's the leaderboard doing? Okay.
>> Oh. Okay. All right, let's see how the
leaderboard's is
>> check out the leaderboard, see if we're
holding on.
Huh.
Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Well, I'd like to thank Christina for
being here at Google. Uh we'll
>> [laughter]
>> give you your paycheck at the back.
Uh-oh. Oh. We'll pay out your vacation.
We're very humane with that. No, it's
great so far, but this stuff happens,
right? Things can break, day two
happens, load happens, things like that.
It's okay.
So, how do we have to think about a
little more than that? Cuz if you ask
most developers, where are you spending
your time with AI? Guess what you're not
doing. Day two stuff. Deployment,
monitoring, fixing. Most devs are like,
"Hey, I'm using it to build document
code." That's awesome.
But not enough of us yet are making this
part of our day two journey. So, how do
we think about that a little bit more?
How do we actually take advantage of
what AI can do for us on day two? So,
over these next 30-ish minutes or so,
we're going to show three agent-first
workflows. These are going to take these
prototypes and turn them into something
more reliable, more production grade.
We're going to use antigravity, Google
Cloud, a number of components. Let's do
something to make any of these fun
vibe-coded apps something more legit.
So, we want to start with agent-first
debugging. I mean, some of you might
like debugging. It's fine. You're
probably fun at parties because you talk
about this a lot. [laughter]
But Denise, can you set the stage for us
here? What's it look like to do real
agent-first debugging? Yeah, so I mean,
when something crashes, most of the time
you're going to have to go through all
of these logs, and who really wants to
do that? Cuz I know I don't. You know,
you got to go look at your
configurations, see if you made a
mistake. You go look at the performance
metrics to see if there's any issues
with latency and everything, but nobody
wants to do that.
You know, so what if we took our agent,
our agentic developer tool, in our case
we're going to use antigravity,
and what if we took that and we let it
do the job for us? Right? Why do all of
that manual task ourselves?
So,
it crashed, and we want to know what
happened. So, let I am going to use,
because I'm kind of lazy, I don't want
to actually type it. I'm going to use
the voice input and ask,
"Find out what's wrong with Dino Quest."
So, going to kick it off, and notice how
I do not actually tell it, "Where is my
logs? Where is my Dino Quest service?"
I was able to do it all with just
telling it what to do.
And the reason why I was able to do that
is because we have the Google-managed
MCP servers. To be able to safely
connect our agentic tool to MCPs and our
Cloud Run and our services.
And so, by doing that, and as you can
see, there's lots and lots of them
available, we don't have to juggle with
API keys. We don't have to go into the
console and go click around and do all
of that stuff. All of our data and our
services from from Google Cloud is
available for the agent.
So, let's go back to Any Gravity and see
Look at it right there. So, as I was
talking, all of that happened, right?
Like, would you normally be able to do
that if you were manually debugging?
Nope. So, it told me that this is
actually caused by a 503 service
unavailable. I think all of you putting
it there put a lot of the issues onto a
load. So, going on, um
we know what the issue is now. We want
to actually fix the problem. So, I'm
going to ask Any Gravity again. Okay.
"Can you look at the code for the Dino
Quest game and fix what caused the
issue?"
So, here,
send it through,
and it is going to go and work and do
all of that. But, as it's going,
Richard, why don't you tell us about the
developer knowledge MCP? Because I think
that's a great MCP for people to use.
Yeah, I mean, you mentioned Look,
there's over 50 of those managed MCP
servers you can use today from
everything from BigQuery to Cloud Run.
One of them, which everybody should use,
is called the developer knowledge API or
developer knowledge MCP. What this is is
an MCP server that fronts over a dozen
different Google Doc bases, from AI to
Cloud to Firebase to all these different
components. So, you can just say, "Hey,
I need something." And it goes and
searches any of our docs and pulls back
the latest version into your coding
tool. So, all of a sudden, you're not
guessing, "Am I using the wrong version,
the right version?" You're getting a 8
to 12-hour at the latest snapshot of the
documentation into your agentic tooling.
So, doesn't matter if you're using Cloud
Code, you're using Code X, you're using
Anti-gravity, pull the latest of Google
documentation into your tool and make it
easy to use.
Yeah, I mean, that's very helpful
because one of the problems is always
using outdated date like outdated
information. And then your agent's not
going to actually do what you want it to
do.
>> All right, so let's go on and and looks
like Anti-gravity has finished and it
said that the issue was actually in our
leaderboard. And it went ahead and made
the code changes for us over here in the
main.py file. I didn't have to actually
do anything myself. I just let it go.
And so, typically what we would want to
do is go and commit it to GitHub and
we're going to redeploy and Anti-gravity
can do this for me. But because we have
a little thing a few things up our
sleeve later on, I'm not going to
actually deploy it now so that we can
show you something better later. I like
it.
>> Christina.
Sounds good. I know here in Google we're
all about transparency, right? And
things like this happen, we wanted to
make it out for people, right? So, for
those of you who kind of suffer through
the game, we want to give you some
treats back in the game. And as you
know, um
what we have right here is Data Agent
Kids. Data Agent Kids gives me some kind
of visibility into my data source. The
reason why I talk about data source is
because I live coded this game 3:00 a.m.
in the morning. Well done. You're a
trooper.
Right. This is where my dark circle came
from. It was it got very fuzzy
at the end. I kind of forgot where I
store everything.
And this is where this came very helpful
because I was able to kind of figure out
where things are without me needing me
to actually go in and figure out things
out. So, what I'm going to do here, I
have the data agent kit installed in my
antigravity right here.
And
um, let's go ahead and then start to
head over to our antigravity.
Right.
So, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
ask our antigravity with data agent kit
to look through all my data sources. And
as a treat for you, as you can see all
the document databases that I have cuz
I've been live coding with AI Studio and
AI Studio directly uses most of the time
it goes to use Firestore as my database
and it's a document database. And to
update it is not as simple as, "Oh, I'm
just going to write a sequel." It's not
as simple. Sometimes you have to write
code to insert a document. So, it's kind
of a messy thing to do. So, yeah, so I
want to use natural language. Let's head
over here and then let's go ahead and do
it. Um
Add five treats for all users.
And I'm going to send it in. So, what
happens now is this data agent kit, not
only it has access to the MCP server, it
also comes with skills. The skill has
the know-how, so it doesn't just
communicate to my server, it also knows
how to do that properly. So, as you can
see right here, the agent actually
suggests
it actually wrote a Python file and it
wants to execute this Python file. And
it doesn't just execute because
antigravity is aware of what's going on.
It doesn't just go want to go ahead and
just run application. It's not so
secure. Yeah. So, it's going to ask for
my permission.
>> That's good. And I'm going to go ahead
and run it. So, it's going to answer
five treats to three users.
Awesome. We only have three users. Huh,
I thought we had more. I don't know.
They crashed on three users, huh? Oh,
that's right. Oops. All right, so let's
head over to the Dino Quest and see if
we have the treat added. Awesome. As you
can see, we have added five treats to
our user.
And as for the announcement, because we
want all of you to know that
announcements here
and you know, with the with the
announcement, it's even worse because I
also forgot where I stored it, which is
not a good idea to code at 3:00 a.m. in
the morning. Um so, you know what I'm
going to do? I'm going to also ask
Antigravity to do it for me again. So,
here I am. I'm going to head over here
and say
add an announcement with title sorry for
the crash with a message that says they
each get five treats.
And I'm going to ask it to do it for me.
So, what this agent does, it's going to
go through all my data store and
luckily, this is not a very complex use
case, so it was able to figure out where
I'm storing my announcement. It will
then create the document for me and even
formulate a message for me. As you know,
my English is not that good, so it's
going to formulate a very nice sorry
message so everybody can see. So, for
those for those of you wants to see the
message, if you go over here and refresh
the message, there you go. The message
has been inserted into the document.
Isn't that great, Richard? That is
amazing.
You've redeemed yourself.
Uh so, that was awesome. I mean, it's
you're you're interacting with the
database, doing things that not all of
us have every skill, but you actually
are baking skills into your workflow
where you can do all these things.
That's amazing.
Those agent first workflows, though, if
you see that, this is a mindset shift,
right? This isn't how we're all used to
working. There's something new here. And
part of this, too, is thinking about
this new way to debug. We're connecting
to live environments, pulling logs,
iterating on this. So, how do we think
about this new approach and plan and and
and specifications, things like that.
It's pretty exciting.
But, let's look at kind of this next
piece. Now that we have happy users,
hopefully, you can try it again and keep
messing around with it. How do we grow
the app? How do we fix it, optimize it,
make it even better, add performance
improvements? So, our very second
workflow we want to do is how do we
optimize? How do we understand user
behavior? How do we fine-tune the game
to make it even more competitive for
players? And
the log data might actually tell us what
kind of dinosaurs people are making,
playing, whatever. But, instead of
writing all the pipelines with ETL and
analyzing data, there's probably a
better way to do this with an agent.
There's always a better way. Why do we
want to do things manually, right? Like,
that's just time-consuming.
And so, by doing that, it's like we can
use the data agent kit again.
And here, data agent kit is an extension
for our IDE, and we can see that we can
have access to all these big query
things.
And so, in addition to using the data
agent kit, we're going to be using the
big query MCP, as well as a custom agent
skill that we built for this actual
purpose. And here, I have our skill
open, just so it's not magic. You can
see that we actually have a skill here,
and it's going to lay out what it's
going to do.
This skill provides us a blueprint to
automate a zero ETL analytics pipeline.
So, what it's going to do is it's going
to create a log writer sync to be able
to stream the live logs directly into
the big query data set. And that means
no manual data plumbing that you needed
to do.
Then it's going to use the big query MCP
to be able to run a series of parallel
queries, and then just extract all that
data that we got from the logs. And then
lastly, it takes all of that data and
it's going to create us an interactive
dashboard.
And so, question is how do we run the
skill? Well, we can run the skill
directly in Anagog Gravity. And as you
see the theme, we can do everything all
in one place. But because this takes a
little bit of time because we have a lot
of data there, I've run this beforehand
cuz I'm pretty sure right now at what is
it? 3:30 something, you don't want to be
sitting here watching me run this. So,
I've run this beforehand and all I had
to do is tell it to run that report for
my DynoQuest app and then it told me the
actual pipeline that I had shown
earlier.
And then it goes and says it created a
log report and it created our feature
insights so that we know what we want
from our next version and created an
interactive dashboard. So, let's take a
look at the dashboard that we have and
here it is. So, this was what was
generated. So, now we can see what the
traffic overview, how many requests
there were, um how many server logs and
the win rate by dyno type. So, I
probably should have
cho- chose speedy earlier because
apparently speedy is a 54% win.
I know. I did choose tank. Well, at
least it wasn't too bad. I balanced was
the worst.
And then how many treats per outcome and
the top reused dinosaur. We could assume
that if somebody uses this dinosaur a
lot, it's probably a good dinosaur. Um
but let's go back over here. So, in
addition to building this dashboard, you
actually now have all of the data from
BigQuery.
And you can just go straight into
Antigravity and start asking it
questions in natural language. No more
need of getting sick, how do I build my
SQL query? I mean, it's been a long time
since I've actually thought about all
the select statements and you know, all
of that stuff. And go and ask it. But in
addition to asking it information, you
can draw the distribution graphs just
straight here. So, what's really nice
about this is that you don't have to go
click back to the console, do SQL
queries, do, you know, come and give my
graph and then you can do everything all
in one place, no context switching. And
I'm pretty sure there's no way that even
though I said it it takes a little bit
of time of 9 minutes, there's no way you
could have done this manually in that
short period of time. So, what do you
think about that? It's impressive. I
mean, be honest with me, how much of a
data person are you? Like, was a lot of
this just helping you do things with the
skills and the tools where this isn't
your wheelhouse? Or how should people
here feel like you're doing some pretty
sophisticated things here? It's been a
while since I've been messing with SQL,
and you know, we we do a lot of coding
more for the front end, but not so much
of all of this. So, for me of thinking
about how am I going to put these
queries is just something I just don't
think about from my everyday basis.
Amazing. So, we went from millions of
logs and things like that or potentially
into some sort of clear actionable
features in a couple of minutes. That's
the sort of leverage you hope to get
from skills and tools in this agentic
workflow. If I were building an app a
year ago, I mean, I might be
intimidated. So, I was asking you, it's
a big query and doing these
sophisticated queries, ETL pipelines,
that's not my wheelhouse. But you're
showing how using these skills and MCPs
and tools, a lot of us can just get
different work done. Which is pretty
wild stuff. And that data agent kit,
should check that out. It's all managed.
All those skills and MCPs get updated.
You get the latest and greatest whenever
we improve that.
All right.
So, we've debugged.
We've optimized with these agent-first
workflows.
I think let's go up a notch for that
final demo. How do we think about an
agent-first remediation, actually detect
and fix problems?
Yeah, I mean,
nobody wants to get We all know crashes
happen at any time, right? Like, right
now there could be a crash at somebody's
app right now. I hope not, but I'm
pretty sure there is. And nobody wants
to just drop everything that they're
doing or if it's in the middle of the
night, you know, Christina might be up
at 3:00 a.m., but not everybody's going
to be up at 3:00 a.m. to debug these
issues. Nobody wants to be debugging.
So, what if we did all the stuff
manually? And I'm By manually, now I'm
talking about us anti-gravity and doing
it. It was faster, but we don't want to
do that.
>> You're still involved.
>> Right? We still We still have to go do
it. So, what if we did all of that 24/7
autonomously without us even watching?
So, we decided that we are going to
build a self-healing system.
So, introduce to you our Dino agents.
These are our custom agents. And of
course, they're called Dino agents cuz
we have a Dino game. Um you know, we
It's got to be Go with the theme. And
so, these are our Dino agents. There's
the remediation agent, the CI agent, and
the CD agent.
These are three custom agents that we
built, and they all specialize in
different tasks.
We hosted these agents on Cloud Run
because this is where our Dino Quest
game is hosted as well. So, by having it
on the same platform as our actual app,
we're able to get a secure, low latency,
and cost-effective architecture. And
this shifts all our manual
troubleshooting into an intelligent and
scalable assistant.
These Dinos, these agents of ours, use
uh the Agent Development Kit ADK as our
framework. And you By using ADK, it
saves us from writing a custom
boilerplate for state management, tool
routing, and retry logic. We also take
advantage of ADK's skill tool set to be
able to get the Dinos' expertise cuz
we're able to load custom domain
playbooks in order to codify all of that
knowledge that they have into a
repeatable work workflow.
And what's nice is that all of these
agents are production-ready observable
agents.
>> [snorts]
>> So, we're going to see all our agents in
action later, but let's focus on our
first agent, the remediation agent.
Our remediation agent is an always-on
SRE and is able to catch and fix
failures on its own and fix the root
cause.
So, the way that it works is that our
app is always going to be logging into
our cloud logging, and that's by
default, right? Whenever it sees an
error, it's going to trigger our event
arc and our pub/sub.
That is going to wake up our remediation
agent, and our remediation agent is
going to go and investigate the issue,
and it's going to go fix the issue using
Gemini.
So, after all of that is done, that it
remediation agent does its job, and it's
going to go and open a GitHub PR with
the fix, and it notifies you with Slack.
So, all you have to do is, oh, I got a
Slack notification. You don't actually
have to be at your computer. You could
actually have it on your phone with your
Slack. So, all of this is an is an
asynchronous event-driven process that
turns every error into an actionable
job. Awesome.
>> want to show them how it works?
>> Exactly. That's where the agents work.
So, while you two are, you know, uh
talking right here, I uh deployed our
Dino agents into the system, right? So,
sorry, Richard. I have to break your app
again.
>> Again? Again. Sorry. Just got back in my
good graces.
>> breaking things. I have to do it. So,
let's head over here and start breaking
the system, right? But this time,
I think we'll be fine cuz we have the
Dino agent, right? So, if we come over
here
and look in here, this is By the way,
there is a little code right on the
left-hand side where you can see our
Dino agents are working, right? So,
let's see. Looks like our system is
working hard trying to uh
It's working hard to crash.
>> Crash. Right. [laughter] Right. It's
working really hard to crash. Your 3:00
a.m. system looks like a fever dream. I
know, right?
>> That was pretty intense-looking. Ooh.
Looks like it didn't crash for some
reason. No. No?
>> You can't break it on purpose. I don't
know I if I can.
Maybe it's trying to self-remediate.
>> Yeah, maybe it already helped and
self-remediated while you had to deploy
the agent.
>> that's okay. So, we'll see how that
goes. So,
Oh.
Did the Dino Quest Okay, perfect. It
died.
>> It died. All right, sorry. Thank you.
So, what you're seeing right here, feel
free to watch this live. It's right
here. There is This is how the agent
works. So, you have the remediation
agent listening to all the problems, and
I'm going to just visualize it for you
right here. So, the remediation kind of
comes up and work, and it figures out,
you know, your system kind of just
crashed, so I'm going to help you
remediate it. So, that's why it went off
and remediated. But, not only does that,
Yeah. remember what Denise was talking
about like it went off and fixing the
code, right? So, it went off and fixed
the code. Not only fixes the code, it
actually pushes things into our GitHub
repository, right?
>> Awesome. So, as you can see here, um
So, I don't know cuz our agent right
here, you can see now, "Hey, That's
right.
>> it kind of breaks, right?" So, you can
kind of see it creates a leaderboard PR,
so it tells us exactly what went wrong,
right? It's cool. And it tells us, you
know, "Since something went wrong, I'm
going to help you fix it." So, it even
creates a very nice
branch right here that tells you in this
particular instance, this is the the
code that was fixed for you, right? So,
very nice. And in the
in the Slack message, I'm also getting a
message coming from the Dino Quest,
which, you know, kind of tells us
exactly what went wrong. Perfect.
Awesome. So, I hope you are following us
at this moment. So, see this agents are
working. Did you Did you see when you
were looking at the monitor, did you see
that the agents starting to dance with
each other? Yeah. That's the part where
we have the A2A.
So we are not just having one single
agent, we have multiple agents. They're
trying to work together. There you go.
You see that? They're working together.
Okay. Is that what that is? That's yeah,
so that's why I have the the swarms of
agents working together.
>> See, they love working with you.
>> Settle down, agents. Exactly. Perfect.
Yeah, so that's it. Um Richard, so you
know what we This is what we have so
far. Okay.
As you can see, we have our agent. This
is how it's built. So all these dancing
funny agents and all that kind of stuff
was built with ADK. Yep. And also
it has everything that you need in order
to make it secure. So every agent
inherits I am
um securities. So my CI agent doesn't go
off and deploy things. Mhm. And my
really agent doesn't have access to
build my image. So everything is
inherited, so it doesn't go off and do
crazy stuff. And also because we are
accessing a lot of external systems like
the messaging system that we have back
there and also the GitHubs, we want to
store all the secrets somewhere very
secure. So this is why we're storing it
in the secret managers. Awesome. Isn't
that amazing? That was awesome. Yeah.
Cool.
Woo.
And [applause] because of
Thank you very much. I know you're
impressed, but you know, it's okay. Keep
monitoring the agents. Um so if you if
you all the agents are are deployed on
Cloud Run.
Right? Yeah. And the Cloud Run, the good
thing about Cloud Run is it goes dormant
when it's when we're not using it.
And when there's errors, it wakes up.
And after it wakes up, what does it do?
It fixes bugs for me.
>> Work. Yeah, exactly. Puts them into
work, working hard for me, so I don't
have to be
you know, called in the middle of my
date or my dinner with my friends.
>> [laughter]
>> Um and then when it's done, it will then
shut down and
you don't have to pay for it. Isn't that
great?
>> That's the best.
So,
I know money is great. I know all of you
care about money much, but I'm pretty
sure a nerd like you and hopefully
me and hopefully you,
really like to see how agents are built,
right? So, this is one of the tools I
want to introduce to you that how I
built my agent. I built everything from
ADK and building from scratch is never
easy, right? So, you want to have some
kind of tools to help you to how to how
to build this. And I'm using something
called agent CLI. The agent CLI
It's Okay, let me put it on the top so
everybody can see it.
This is typing life, right? Make it a
tad bigger for everybody. Can you zoom
in a tad? There you go. Thank you.
All right. So, this agent CLI
allows us to It helps us to build,
govern, also scale and optimize our
agent. So, I'm going to So, do you want
to see how I built the agent, right?
Cool.
Awesome. But, we don't want to be here
all day. So, I'm going to show you how
we get started.
>> [laughter]
>> Unless you want to stay here with me all
day.
>> us off. Yeah, I'm sure.
So, let's create a new agent. And what
do you want to call this agent? Well,
since we have dinosaurs and everything's
dinosaur themed, let's do a T-Rex agent.
You like the T-Rex name? Yeah.
You don't want to spell Rex as Rex.
>> to think about it. What the T-Rex
agent's actually going to do [laughter]
though? We'll figure it out. We'll vibe
it.
Anyway, so call it agent. Since
I feel like I've been talking for a long
time, so let's just go ahead and create
prototype. Mhm.
And then just go ahead and create. Yes.
So, what it will do is going to create a
boiler plate code that has everything
there for me. So, if you head over to
T-Rex
and then let's see what's inside the
T-Rex. It actually creates a lot of the
things for me already. So it creates
um
an agent code right here. So if you can
kind of quickly see what's in the agent.
So you can see it creates
it creates an 88 code. It shows you what
is in agent. It shows you how to build
an agent with the instructions. So this
is how your agent should behave and also
a lot of the tools that you can include
in your agent. So it's all there for me.
And as well as it
it includes all the test. So I can use
it to test and evaluate my agents.
>> That's great. Yeah, isn't it great? And
also we also have all the um
the files needed to containerize it so I
can deploy later on.
That's great, right? Amazing. Awesome.
So now we have all the agents ready.
Let's go ahead and hand it over back to
you, Richard. Yeah, so agent CLI, check
that out. Free, easy to use. You've seen
data toolkit, a lot of these things easy
to use, tap into. So more than that, I
want to highlight this. This is
something you all have been asking for
for a long time. I'm sorry it's taken a
while.
But how do we make sure we have more
control over our our cloud cost spend?
So coming very soon are these spend
caps. These are in private preview, but
these help you set and enforce budgets
on the APIs for things like Cloud Run,
Gemini APIs and more.
And what happens here is these these
particular caps pause traffic once your
budget is reached. So you can't blow it
up and then wake up in the morning and
destroy your budget. So we're going to
add this to more and more services, give
you more confidence that you're not
going to destroy your spending plans.
Pretty good stuff.
All right, so this was some great
engineering. Agent CLI is pretty awesome
as well.
It's opinionated. Like you saw it had a
set structure for e-vals and and certain
codes. So all those sorts of things you
can still customize that as you want.
But now that we've stabilized this game,
is it completely bonkers to maybe ask
for another feature, another level or
something like that, we can do that,
right?
So, can we can we ship this code on
another branch and ship a new feature of
the app?
We definitely
>> for you to do it cuz this keeps
breaking, but
we could try. Why do you keep on asking
her for to do extra things?
>> keep testing her. Raise the bar.
>> [laughter]
>> So, yes, we definitely can. Um so, we
created our own autonomous CI CD
pipeline. You kind of already seen a lot
of the details earlier, but before we're
going to get into the details, you know,
CI CD pipelines take a little bit of
time. So, we're going to kick it off
first and then we're going to talk about
it. So, this time I'm actually going to
kick it off on Slack, which means that I
can kick it off from any at any time,
anywhere. So, here I'm going to go in
and do CI agent run CI on branch level
two.
So, going to kick it off. Oops. Let's go
show that at the bottom. So, going to go
on and start start running this. But, so
what we did is that we are while this is
all running, we're going to look at the
details and what we did was we have our
last two agents that we showed earlier.
We have our CI agent to be able to do
our continuous integration. Um you want
to go next slide? Yep. Um and so, we
have our CI agent with our continuous
integration and then that agent is
supposed to remediate all of the issues
that it has as well as doing um a
security scan as well as testing. Then
we have our CD agent, which is our
continuous delivery agent, and it
deploys the app, it learns the
deployment patterns, and it does
monitoring with auto rollback. So, if
there's any failures with the
deployment, it's going to roll back to
make sure that our app is in a good
place.
So, all of these agents talks to each
other with agent to agent, A to A, and
this almost makes it where it's like a
team member collaborating. Rather than
one agent telling some general agent
some message to tell the other agent, it
can actually talk to each other like
normal human beings.
We can also communicate with Slack as
you see. We were able to get
notifications. We're able to kick it off
from the pipeline from Slack and we're
using the Slack webhook that's
available.
And this, unlike static pipelines, this
these agents are very intelligent and it
can actually make decisions for us so we
don't always have to tell it what to do.
Cool. You want to show Of course. Yeah.
These agents
with the two agents that we built so
far, right? And there could be more
agents in your environment. And if you
want to put them to work together, you
need to know where they are. Yeah. And
this is where why where we have the
agent registry. And this is where we
have looks like we our agent doesn't
have a lot of friends.
I mean, we'll give them some social work
maybe sometimes skills later, but these
agents we have three of them. CI agents,
CD agents, and our cycle agents as well.
So, if you look into it, so if if you
look into registry, so these are the
friends and that tells you how to locate
your agents. Where do they live? How do
you call them? And it also provides a
personality like knowing what this agent
does, right? So, there's description of
what this agent actually thinks and how
it process things. Not only that, it
also provides you with all the tools it
has access to. So, now if I want to use
this agent, I know what other things I
can do with this agent. So, it gives you
a much more clarity onto things that you
use and to do that.
Awesome.
Perfect. Um
right here. So,
awesome. So, if we look at our CI agent,
right? So, our CI agent is right here.
And what it does, it actually takes in
um
notifications and it takes in
um things to do from my other agents.
So, it communicates with A2A, right? And
it also take messages coming from Slack.
And it also
uses a lot of things together, right?
So, it takes in decisions, it uses a
skill to think about things, and then
what it does, it use this information
that's given from the Slack messages,
from the other agents, it will determine
if I want to run what kind of test. So,
it will if you have a lot of front-end
code, it will do run front-end test. If
it does, you know, quick change some
things, it will go through security,
right? So, that's what it do. So, it's
smart. It doesn't do a traditional
pipeline, which is kind of does one and
two and three. It's not sequential,
because it thinks for itself. And then
it's going to use a lot of the Google
very well battle-tested services, like
Workload Build, that helps you to build
images, and also Artifact Artifact
Registry to help you hold the images as
well, right? And after it's done, it's
going to send the um the notification or
message to the CD agents, and the CD
agent is our release manager. Uh when I
was kind of coding this, when I was
having fun with like running all these
three agents, kind of they're running
together, actually there's once where I
made a small mistake, and the message
well, I accidentally deleted one of the
revision, and the CI agent was telling
the CD agents like,
um you know, can you please deploy this
image that doesn't even exist? You know
what happened? The CD agent actually
went back and tell CI agents like, "Hey
dude, what do you mean? I haven't seen
this message." And they um back and
forth, back and forth, until they figure
out what's wrong, and the CI agent we
ran the whole thing, and the CD agent
eventually does the whole release. So,
it's very smart. I was very surprised,
and you can see them kind of doing the
dance back and forth, cuz I was testing
the image. It was super fun. Wow. So,
the CD agents gets it um it um sees the
changes, looking into all the changes in
your code, and get decide on the risk
score. The risk score is on how much
What's the risk of, you know, deploying
that into the environment and things can
go wrong. So, it will use a score to
actually determine the canary release.
And it will monitor this for a duration,
and since this is a demo, we'll look for
like 30 seconds.
Um and then we'll deploy everything into
production. So, that will be That's
That's the whole process of um
of our C of of our CD pipelines. Wow.
That's
pretty cool system. It's learning. It's
scary to me, but uh your system learns.
Yeah.
That's great. So, we showed that live,
right? Throughout this session we've
seen examples of Agentic tools doing
different steps we see here. We plug
this into antigravity thanks to MCPs,
thanks to skills pulling in live log
information, doing database queries.
That's amazing. Now, you can build your
own Agentic workflows. We showed you
with that Agentic CLI, that Agent CLI.
You can build your own things here, and
I don't know. We won't want to always
spend all of our time on day two. So, if
we can use these tools to use the
platform that backs our agents, it just
makes life a lot easier. So,
all the problem-solving that we love as
engineers hasn't gone away. It's just
shifted around. We're doing design work.
We're planning work. We're interacting
with the systems. I think that's pretty
amazing.
So, enough talking. Level two is
shipped, right? You shipped it? It's
there. All right. So, if you scan this
this time,
we can see who can play now in the
apparently terrifying volcano for these
distressed dinosaurs,
and see how this works. You have to pass
level one in order to get get to level
two, but I got past level one. Yes. You
have to pass level one. Getting through
level one is hard. Shortcuts? Yeah. Left
right left right? No. B A start? No.
We should have coded that in.
Awesome. So,
you're going to be playing that in your
free time. But look, if you want to
incorporate these three agentic
workflows in your own applications, you
can scan these QR codes and actually
follow the tutorials, which has all the
code that we demo today. How awesome is
that? They took everything they built
and put this into a lab that you two all
of you can run yourselves. So, I'll keep
that up for just a second. Cuz again,
this shouldn't just be something we all
watched here. It should be something
let's go try it. This whole event is
about getting hands-on, building the
confidence to go do some of this
ourselves. So, take advantage of those
code labs and see what you can do. So,
let's go build. Let's go have some fun
and uh thank you for joining us today
and staying cool.
>> [music]